let's talk about joe biden
so in this report from the daily mail
they mentioned that the supreme court
has voted 63 to block biden's vaccine
mandates however a disappointed joe will
tell businesses to adopt the rules
anyway and says it's up to states to do
the right thing biden has urged
businesses to bring in vaccine mandates
on their own and push states to do the
right thing after the supreme court
voted 63 to block his sweeping rules on
private companies in a crushing blow to
his pandemic response the high court did
however allow a vaccine minute for
employees at healthcare facilities
receiving federal dollars to go into
effect now there's an important
distinction here joe biden is saying
ignore the supreme court in a certain
sense but the supreme court did not rule
that vaccine mandates are completely
illegal the supreme court ruled that joe
biden doesn't have the authority through
osha to mandate businesses require
vaccinations so joe biden comes out and
says then it's up to you guys to
implement these because i can't force
you to do it now you know i think it's
going to happen i think i think the blue
states and i think all the big companies
are going to do it anyway mm-hmm
fortunately though it means i guess like
the daily wire won't have to well
they're going to try to do it but
there's also a very interesting article
also from the daily mail talking about
how a lot of the cases are flatlining in
a lot of these major democratic states
and if this goes along with the theory
that i've been talking about and many
other medical professionals have been
talking about for a few weeks now there
should be a sharp decline in the numbers
just like we have seen in south africa i
might be wrong on that assessment and
that theory but if that's the case
they're going to have a hard
justification for more lockdowns more
mandates and i think this is their kind
of last push and i think this is a major
setback against their agenda and i don't
see it going further from here from my
perspective it's kind of a dilemma for
businesses because on the one hand
they're dealing with employees some of
whom are karen's right they they want
that vaccine mandate and they want
double masking and they they're scared
to death
but there's other employees that say i'm
not going to do it and you're going to
lose me and those may well be some of
their most important employees but you
have the chief executive officer of the
united states saying
i got an offer for you that you can't
refuse
and if you say no i'm going to send some
of these agencies to check out your
stuff and make sure that you're in full
compliance with osha full compliance
with this there are so many rules and
regulations that every company in
america is surely violating right now
because they couldn't possibly know what
they are biden still has the ability to
make their lives help and what i think a
lot of the big corporations wanted was
the cover of being forced to do it
by by the government and now they're
stuck in this place
and they're going to discover that
they're going to lose a lot of their
talent if they push forward i got to
tell you you know um i can certainly
sympathize and empathize with a lot of
these businesses because there are
people who
won't admit when they get sick because
they're like no no i'm not sick you know
everything's fine and then they'll come
into work and they'll get people sick
you also have managers who are like i
don't care if you're sick i don't want
my boss yelling at me you better show up
for work and so then you have these you
know executives who are like how do we
stop people from from doing this and
they're like well we can mandate a
vaccine i guess i'm not convinced
vaccine managers are going to solve the
problem so you know ultimately i can
empathize with the problem
uh of people spreading covet and then
your company gets shut down i get it we
had to you know take off for a week
because we got sick and i can see why
people are worried about that but i
think we have to realize we're living
with this yeah well what's you've got to
define the problem what's the problem
today overloading the hospitals that was
the problem two and a half years ago
how do we solve that obviously the
vaccine may reduce symptoms but it
doesn't seem to stop the spread doesn't
seem to stop people from getting it
um i think people are going to the
hospital after they've been vaccinated
so
you're looking to solve the problem that
that solution didn't seem to solve it
well that's that's a good question
what's the problem i don't think there
really is one labor shortages supply
chain problems economics
but no no that's that's
a great point because it's that's not
coveted related anymore yeah and then
why are why is the ap telling them not
to report on single like single case
record increases in certain states what
was that all about because it seems like
they're shifting the narrative from oh
my gosh so many people are getting
decoded or getting covet to being more
like well it's still a problem we still
have to worry about it but we also have
a midterm to win or something i'm not
sure what the strategy is there so what
was the deal with their their decision
to say you can't talk about these
increases these sharp increases you
don't remember they're looking for an
exit strategy and and they've been
scaring the crap out of people for two
years now
and and they're there there is no
problem there's certainly not a problem
that we can do anything about at this
point i mean i think we've created a lot
of collateral damage and remember the
original covid models said if you're
going to flatten the curve you're going
to push out the pandemic
and that was always part of the model
and here we are two years into it and
this is an extraordinary virus in its
behavior
and and i think that all of these
central planners who thought they knew
better are culpable so they they need an
exit strategy and if we can just tone
down the hysteria on the data
maybe we can get out of this before the
midterm i think it's very yeah it's got
to be political absolutely
i definitely agree you we've been
talking about it for a few weeks now and
this could be why jake tapper said you
know the hospital numbers are inflated
this is why the cdc came out and said 75
percent of debts are because of four or
more comorbilities this is why the new
york governor came out said around 40 of
the hospitalizations are literally
people who were there not because of
corona but with corona because of other
incidences and there's more and more of
these announcements something is
definitely going on here and i think
there's definitely a bigger agenda at
play here i figured out luke's agenda
by saying words like comorbility yeah
the ai on youtube can't track the words
he's saying to censorship you should
have seen what i was saying a specific
kind of medication a year ago oh i will
remember it forever you guys remember
last year i'm not going to say it here
but there was a specific way i was
specifically mentioning stuff you're
developing your own sensor proof
language
i'm going to play it off like that but
that's not the case
but there's this uh there's this font
that allows people who are dyslexic to
read read it oh cool and it's really
interesting it's got like thicker
portions on parts of the letters and i
feel like that's kind of like this luke
will say the word comorbility and the ai
just goes like i'm not familiar
who was it was it uh leonardo da vinci
wrote in code because it was illegal the
church would have him executed if he
they knew he was talking about the stuff
he was talking about heliocentric model
i think that was da vinci galileo maybe
wrote
wasn't alice in wonderland and through
the looking glass
you know it was meant to be metaphorical
supposed to be uh representing the
problems of government and everything
like that you gotta hide from the
algorithm you gotta slightly move
through it it's always been the case wow
well regardless of algorithms big tech
is a big problem in terms of limiting
speech and shutting down dissent and
shutting down conversations
but uh
i i feel at this point
with what biden is saying i don't know
if the democrats are going to get the
message before the midterms right how
how does joe biden come back from the
supreme court struck down his mandate he
then
double triples down saying do it anyway
and then we're supposed to
we're we're going to expect democrats to
change their minds in a few months and
be like everyone's free now vote for us
because if they keep running on
lockdowns they're going to lose yeah
well he's got two fundamental problems
one
is that the people
that
were forced to be vaccinated the people
that lost their jobs or the people that
are looking at empty grocery shelves
are going to show up and midterms are
low turnout elections so the midterms
are going to be dominated by people that
have suffered under the under the biden
regime and the other problem and this
goes back to what james carville so
famously said it's the economy stupid
it's going to be very hard to fix what
they've done
in terms of supply chains in terms of
employment problems in terms of all
these things that people are feeling at
the at the very local level
there's there's no way to turn that
around in time so i think they're faced
with
with what they're doing is let's just
keep doubling down and hope for a
miracle but
it seems like political suicide to me
yeah i agree with you if if people came
out of the lockdown and the economy was
where it was three years ago i think
it'd be fine people would be like cool
biden all the way but dude they inflated
the economy so heavily by like 100
percent almost yeah did you did you see
when uh 80 percent kamala harris got
asked if the ticket was gonna stay the
same and she goes look we are focused on
you know today and i'm like it's really
weird she couldn't just be like yeah
you know what i mean i guess she was
like i know what you're trying to do
with the pundits and the talking points
you know because they're saying but we
are focused on what's happening today
and i was just like
just say yes but the reality is the
answer is not yes
she's not going to be bitching
in a few months they're going to throw
away biden like the worn puppet that he
is they're going to throw him by the
wayside he's going to be gone and
they're going to bring in someone else
they're they're teasing they're they're
literally teasing hillary um and and
other people that they're trying to
bring to the forefront buddha judge is
another one um i think it might even be
even something like uh michelle obama or
oprah who knows what they're doing but i
i do not see anyway unless they make uh
you know clones of him um or some kind
of gmo creature and put them in the
front of us i don't see how they're
going there is a conspiracy theory they
cloned by no joke or they replace them
or something it's silly but remember
when barack obama said to biden you
don't have to do this do you remember
that quote yep see we always we always
assume the context of that quote is you
don't need to be the man who who tries
to stop donald trump when in reality he
was saying like you don't need
like it was more of a you don't need to
do this like you're not qualified yeah
you are not qualified for this job
and and joe biden listen he hears it and
in his mind he's like this hero saving
the day and biden's like
you you don't need to do that joe let's
uh let's go back to the sun room and get
you your blanket and get you a nap and
joe was like oh true not a shot with a
pressure the the last desperate throws
of george bush 41
was his staff leaking all of this stuff
about how dan quayle was the problem
so if you're blaming your vp for the
failure of your presidency
you're probably already done
i don't think they ever planned on biden
going beyond one term and they can they
can they can play it up like they did
intend for him to be a two-term
president but the reality was we all
know what joe biden is he was the
corporeal form that they asked for just
a warm body that was not donald trump
it's like an old episode of star wars
yeah yeah star start start trek star
trek they got what they wanted and now
we are all much worse off for it
but if you are a wealthy political elite
sitting atop your ivory tower
they're happier that trump isn't in in
in office
even though everyone else is suffering
so long as they're better off because
trump was a bull rampage and through and
they don't care about you i could see if
andrew yang had gotten into presidency
and they were like we're gonna print
five trillion he would be like nah and
he would have been obstructing all this
money printing so like they needed
someone like biden who's just i just
said
anthony i absolutely disagree with you
he would give that money to he would
agree with that money yeah i don't know
he'd be like a lot of them actually it
it does make sense to bolster the
economy by printing more money because
everyone will then have money to spend
and eat food with and you know we should
do it and i actually like andrew yang
but i definitely think he would be like
print money but that would have been
like one point two trillion not six
trillion dollars
with the way that the government does
they would give everyone money and then
give themselves twice as that he worked
for cnn i have absolutely no faith and
trust in that man
i think it's awesome that 1.2 trillion
is considered the fiscally i know
spend money to make money modern
monetary theory is breaking down because
we don't have industry in the united
states we're putting all this money into
something that's not getting us a return
and the money's disappearing thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you